hello everyone and welcome back to
another edition of chess openings
explained as always my name is caleb
denby
and today what i wanted to talk to you
about is a little thing
called basic opening principles and how
you can actually win games very quickly
with them
provided you are applying them correctly
and your opponent is not
and part of the reason i'm doing this
lecture is you know there are a lot of
people out there
online these days you know prescribing
all these
crazy gambits winning 10 moves with the
halloween gambit winning 12 with the
stafford gambit
but i'm here to tell you the the truth
is you win
if you play good moves that is how chess
works
and of course the best moves are always
backed up
well supported by these basic principles
upon which our chess opening
knowledge is founded and so i wanted to
highlight some games
that really do show that you don't need
to do crazy things in the opening to get
a good position
and you don't need to do crazy things in
the opening to win
a chess game and that is the idea for
tonight
so to start off with i wanted to show
you guys a game that i actually played
in this current year
believe it or not not too many of those
floating around but this was an over the
board game
from way back in february that i got to
play
and i had the white pieces here against
an opponent who was rated around
1950 2000 some somewhere in that range
right so a little bit lower rated than
me
but definitely not a weak player
and i just want to jump into what we see
going on
in this game so to start with i go
d4 uh alexander goes knight f6
i play c4 e6 knight c3
bishop b4 and we arrive at the nimzo
indian defense right so so far so good
three moves in
moves that makes sense very very common
stuff so far
and i choose this line with the move f3
and this is probably the least
principled move that i play
throughout the entire uh you know
opening here
but the point is it is controlling the
center very very directly right
um and that's why this move is is
perfectly okay for white
it's making a strong claim in the center
a claim that must be responded to
uh and if you're gonna get mad at me for
doing it on move four
and i say that it's you know just like
this is just a line trust me white can
do this
uh i've said this before and people get
mad at me and say yes
but it's not principled you know you're
just openings are all theory look you
played f3 because of its theory it
doesn't make any sense
and i'm trying to say it controls the
center and that
is good enough for move4
but okay alexander meg plays the move d5
challenging my claim to this e4 square
and now to reassert my control over the
center i would like to make this bishop
move out of the way
and i do so with a3 my opponent now has
a choice
the bishop can retreat along this
diagonal or it can capture on c3
in this case my opponent takes on c3 i
take on c3
and black castles so again
you might say that a3 is slightly
unprincipled but the point is it's
making
a black waste time with the bishop so
the time that i waste on a3
is counteracted by the time that black
wastes by moving the bishop again
or as we see in the game if the bishop
captures on c3 and i have to spend
another move to recapture
then my control over the center is
greatly increased so
for the moment i'm sacrificing the
principle of development
for the principle of central control and
that is why
a3 is also a principled move
i play c takes d5 fixing my double pawns
e takes d5 and now the simple move e3
and so i'd like you guys to uh come up
with some ideas
for both sides here how do we think this
game
is actually going to continue what
should white be doing what should black
be doing
um the chat is just making john madden
references
and oh yes i'm answering questions that
i hadn't even read
that's that's good always good when that
happens
we've got a ben feingold reference in
the chat great stuff
so the chat is definitely on the right
track here right
both sides still need to finish
development and that is what
they should be focusing on first and
foremost
so good moves for black
would be actually the move c5
or the move b6 now why are these the two
best moves
in the position well because
really at the end of the day this bishop
uh its highest aspiration in life
unfortunately
is to trade itself off for this bishop
on f1 this bishop on c8
just is never going to be what its
counterpart on f1 is
and you know its goal in life is to make
sure that this guy
doesn't get to d3 and sort of control
the entire board
so that's why b6 is a good move now
similarly
knight c6 is not a great move why is
that
well you take away this option for
yourself to play the move bishop a6 a
little later in the game
why is c5 a good move well because it
exerts pressure
on white's center so all of these three
moves
uh c5 and b6 and then eventually knight
c6 and bishop a6
to uh follow up these are all very
principled moves black is
aiming to finish development on the
queen side
there's also the move bishop f5 for
black which might be appealing to a lot
of you
and this move is also okay for black why
is it okay for black
because it's a principled move it
develops a piece
i personally think that white can get a
little bit of an advantage
in this particular line because this
bishop is a little bit susceptible
to coming under fire with some knight e2
to g3s even some g4 ideas from white
and if white does get the movie e4
through then it's going to be with tempo
on the bishop
but c5 b6 bishop f5 all of these
perfectly reasonable moves
very perfectly reasonable moves what my
opponent does
is rookie 8 which is a little bit too
cavalier with the opening principles in
my opinion
yes it is applying some pressure on the
center
applying pressure to this e3 pawn but
notably
all of these other moves that i was
suggesting
apply pressure on the center with the
goal in mind
to finish development uh very quickly
afterwards you go
c5 so that you can go knight c6 right
you don't want to go knight c6 first and
block in your c
pawn so c5 is very directly aiming to
play knight c6
soon b6 is very directly aiming to
develop the bishop
bishop f5 just outright develops the
bishop and rookie 8 while it's nice to
get the rook
on this half open file it's just a
little bit slower
than uh than what's called for right the
principles say develop your minor pieces
for your major pieces and they're
written that way for a reason
i continue now with bishop to d3 and
black does play this nice move c5
this is all great uh white goes 92 so
far
according to the plan from the chat room
and now black goes knight c6
and yeah i mean so far so good honestly
in my opinion
neither side has done anything too wrong
i was claiming this move rookie 8 is a
little bit inaccurate and i still kind
of stand by that
i would much rather have spent that
tempe getting this bishop to a6 getting
this bishop to f5
but instead black used it to get this
rook to e8
and so now what do i do to crush my
opponent early in the opening
for making a slightly dubious move well
of course
i castle that's right you don't need to
win
with some tactical flurry just because
your opponent plays a move that you know
is slightly
off all you have to do is finish
development
castle your king and your position will
speak for itself
um and now here black plays the move c4
and i want to ask you guys
what you think about the move c4
the chat is asking why knight c6 and not
knight d7 as long as the bishop gets
developed
i'll talk about that in a moment here
but first this question why is c4
this came from an f3 nimzo mr democracy
and f3 nimzo
so yeah c4 is is not great and and the
chat room is mostly
in agreement on on this idea although
their reasonings are a little bit
split and i'm not sure that that i agree
with with many of them
so yeah c4 is is just not a good move
but the reason
isn't because black is breaking a
principle by making too many pawn moves
that's not really the principle being
broken here
um yes black is playing a second pawn
move but in return
white is going to have to sort of move
this bishop again right so the time that
black waste was c4
white is also wasting by playing bishop
c2 it's not like the c2 square is a
massive improvement for this piece
but as some people in the chat were
saying
it allows white to have a big center how
does c4 allow white to have a big center
well if you imagine this pawn on c5 this
pawn is working quite well with the
knight on c6 this is often why
you know it's good to develop the knight
out behind the pawn to pressure
the d4 pawn and pressure the center
these two pieces attack all the same
forward-looking squares and it's quite a
powerful duo
the the c pawn and the knight and with
c4
you are actually giving up sort of all
of your pressure on this d4
pawn now why does that matter well you
have to look a little bit ahead
into the early middle game plans to
understand why this is important
right white played the move f3
on move four what is white aiming for
white is definitely aiming for control
of the e4 square
and someone else mentioned that yes c4
might be weak after e4 but
i don't really think that's the case
it's more that e4
is easy to play now because black is
lacking all of the pressure on white's
center
that this c pawn was affording him so
the principle being broken here is the
principle of central control
this pawn on c5 challenged white's
center and now
by moving this pawn to c4 you control
the d3 square
but that's not in the center of the
board and that is firmly in white's
territory
and now white has a very distinct
advantage
black played b6 and what have i done
i've done absolutely nothing special
this game
i played the f3 nimzo i followed it up
with
a3 which you know again it's move
five uh if you can't remember five moves
in theory
then you you might need to do a little
bit more studying at a certain point but
beyond that
it's not just that i was playing
theoretical moves because after rookie
eight it's not a theoretical position
all i was doing is developing my pieces
and
following my plan just just following
principles alone
and already i think white is uh very
close to having just
an excellent excellent advantage in this
position
so how do i follow it up well this
bishop's developed
this knight's off the back rank uh my
king is castled
now i need to figure out what to do with
the remainder of my pieces here
how do i activate my bishop my two rooks
and
my queen probably my opening choice is
going to give you a hint in this regard
but the opening itself in my opinion is
not over
until i figure out what i'm doing with
these pieces so
chat how do i solve the problem of these
four pieces left on the back row here
pin the knight on f6 well i'd love to oh
that's highly illegal something is wrong
with
pinning the knight on f6 it the the
program will not let me play it
so yes in a sense the key move of course
is this move e4 which is very much
hinted at
by you know my move for f3 it's all
about gaining control of the e4 square
and once what black plays d5 and says
i'm gonna fight you for that square
this is really uh what it's all about
white wants to play e4
and black wants to stop it which again
is why c4 is such a critical
critical mistake by giving up pressure
on d4
it's sort of conceding this e4 idea to
white without a fight
so yes the correct move is knight g3
but i want to talk about why this move
e4 is
so so important and that is because yes
it activates this bishop
but it doesn't just activate my bishop
it activates actually all four of these
pieces
how does it do that well after e4 this
bishop
can spring to life this queen can
also step to the d2 square or come out
along this diagonal if the pawns are
traded
and the rook can come to e1 the other
rook to f1
and literally all of my pieces are going
to be active
they're going to be serving a purpose
and that is the goal of any opening
um and now my opponent sort of loses his
mind here
of course he needs to
either deal with my plan of pushing to
e4
or at the very least finish development
somehow put this bishop at least
somewhere
the best move is actually a pretty
interesting idea here and that is
h5 which on its surface doesn't seem to
be following any type of principles
right it's just a random h pawn push
but it makes sense when you consider
that the idea
is to control the center with the move
h4 forcing this knight away
and delaying white's plan of playing the
move e4
but you know some developing move would
be fine instead my opponent plays the
rather nonsensical
h6 and you know this is how
a lot of games at uh you know the
the amateur levels the club player
levels even sometimes
the the national master level which is
not all that different than a club
player
uh this is how a lot of games are
decided right one player
just sort of
uh kind of forgets you know these
opening principles that
we've been taught so long ago right they
they always
convince themselves hey this position is
the exception this position is different
right clearly i need to play h6 here for
some reason because i'm worried about
like
a bishop g5 or something in some line
but
no uh when in doubt the principles are
your guiding
force and the principles or what you
should be following and that's why moves
like rookie 8
c4 and h6 on their own these moves might
not be so bad
but when you combine these three
slightly weird looking moves together
black is left with this slightly
underdeveloped queen side
and white is left with a huge central
advantage after the move e4
and the game is is over by by move 14.
once white has played this move e4 white
absolutely has a winning advantage
i think if you ask a computer it's
something like plus three here that's
that's how terrible black's position
already is
despite really just these few slightly
inaccurate looking moves that
didn't seem that awful all on their own
but when you combine them all together
it's just a recipe for disaster so
white is winning by move 14 and i'm
punching the microphone that's how
animated i am about it
why is white winning by move 14 well i
didn't sacrifice a piece in the opening
i didn't take anything
on f7 didn't go e4 bishop c4 bishop
takes
i didn't play the cochran's gambit i
didn't play the stafford gambit i didn't
play the nachmanson
i played solid principled chess
i controlled the center and now i have a
winning position
so what's the point i'm trying to make
well i'm not going to name any names
but some people out there jonathan
trance will
always be recommending these funny funny
gambits and while they are a lot of fun
to play
at the end of the day good solid chess
is going to get you very good results
you don't need to always be swayed into
trying to play these tricky openings
where you go go for early checkmates
early things like that
you just control the center develop your
pieces and good things happen
good things just happen to you but
that's enough of me talking let's see
what happens in the game
d takes e4 f takes e4
and i don't know about this decision by
black
on the one hand it sort of makes sense
because now if i ever push
e5 the black knight has the d5 square
but it is of course opening up this rook
on the f file which can be very
dangerous
my opponent plays the slightly weird
knight g4 now
which sort of you know flies in the face
of giving this knight the d5 square
after e5
um no sorry i i
misread the notation i was like why did
knight g4 get played of course bishop g4
got played that makes a lot more sense
um yeah these things happen okay i play
queen e1 because my queen's attacked
and now my opponent fearing for his life
in this position
actually just decided he's he's done he
plays knight takes d4 and sacrifices a
piece that's
that's how bad things had got for him
that's how bad things had got
is plus three not a little too high i'll
flip the engine on right here
i've played e4 flipping on the engine
and give it time give it time
it'll climb up there we're only on depth
18. ah
2.9 at depth 19 3.1
now it starts out at 2.5 but yeah now
it's climbing all the way up to to 2.9
um
now it's down to 2.8 but you take my
point here
you take my point oh 3.1 we got there
and once the engine says what we like we
turn it off so it can't change its mind
um but yeah no this is just really
really bad for black really really bad
for black so bad
that black played knight takes d4 and
sort of gave up the game
um what happens if black just plays a
move like rook c8
well bishop takes h6 is coming queen f2
is coming
after h3 this bishop already sort of
doesn't have any squares
to go to example bishop back to d7
e5 knight d5 queen e4
like black is black is just checkmated
black is just checkmate knight h7 is
maybe a better try
but like these sacrifices it's it's just
it's so bad
so my opponent played knight takes d4
and did go on to lose this game i don't
want to waste your time too much with it
uh here of course rick takes f6 is a
classic
but at this point i'm already just up a
piece so it's
not too not too difficult
e5 queen f4 was played
and there's just too many threats here
and black went ahead
and resigned this position so any
questions on this first game i remember
a question i never answered
um people were saying why not knight d7
for the knight well it comes back to
this idea of having to pressure
white center in this case you might be
saying yes but i want to go
this way but that's just simply you know
not the greatest plan
in the position actually why not well
because knight c4
is actually begging for for e4 to be
played right it's putting this knight on
a square
which relies heavily on the d5 pawn and
the d5 pawn already has a very important
purpose
stopping e4 from from being played so
c5 and knight c6 is a better way of of
developing out
that being said c4 pretty crucial
mistake here
so any other questions
any other questions
in the nimzo is knight c6 generally the
better idea
that's a bit too broad arthas that's a
brit too bit too broad
um you can kind of say in general c6 is
just a better square than d7 for the
knight
for this exact reason you are guarding
this
uh as well as this square that knight d7
also guards but you're attacking d4
you don't block in the bishop so just
like as a general thing yeah c6 is great
for the knight obviously
there are going to be different
specifics in every position and knight
c6
isn't always going to be best for for a
variety of reasons sometimes it's just
not achievable
sometimes you know you want this knight
to go this way
but in the nimzo is still a bit too
broad for for that question
um okay
is the nimzo recommended for lower rated
players you can
play a variety of openings when you're
lower rated
i will say about the nimzo indian it's a
very principled opening
and it's an opening that to my mind
makes sort of logical sense with you
know the the rules that we
we teach beginners so i think it is a
pretty reasonable opening because it
does have this sort of logic to it where
you you sort of feel more comfortable
than in the crazy stuff all right with
that
i want to move on to something else
any generic rule on developing the
knight to the sixth rank versus the
seventh rink
really honestly these are the best
squares for the knights to develop to
if they can get there right obviously i
put my
knight on the second rank um
which is like the seventh and but it was
for the specific purpose of having this
pawn on f3
and guarding on e4 it just depends on
what you want to do
with your pieces but okay let's move
along so
this is another game that i played and
my opponent this time was rated actually
a little bit lower than
alexander meng i think george was around
1850 at the time
we played but uh you could tell
this was one of those slightly older
gentlemen who had been just playing
chess for years and years and years and
had a wealth of experience
so definitely can't count him out you
can never count those kinds of players
out
because you never know sometimes they
just sometimes they just pull out a
really great game
and you're just never expecting it so
george here plays the move d4 i go
knight f6
and then he plays knight c3 okay
so i don't know if anybody's familiar
with d4 knight c3 but this is of course
not the most principled approach of all
time
to the opening why not well we know this
idea
that showed up last game of the night
developing behind the queen's side pawn
it's a very good idea because these
pieces do really well
at controlling the same squares so i
don't know if you can call that an
opening principle
but you know this this is sort of the
standard way of playing is developing
the night out behind the pawn
to control more squares but that's okay
nothing wrong so
far what does what this does do is go
for much more rapid control
of this square on e4 right if you play
c4
you're not controlling e4 right away and
i get time to put my bishop on b4
and play the nimzo indian here i don't
have time for that so i play the move d5
my opponent wants e4
i don't want to give it to him and then
george the the prankster that he is
plays e4 anyways
so who knows what this is who knows what
this
is
[Music]
who knows what's going on here
simon says i know what this is this is
bad
he's got a point he's got a point and
yeah this is just the black martin
deemer gambit
so this game i want to sort of
specifically
go after these crazy style gambits that
are floating around these days and talk
about
you know what do you do when you
actually go up against one of these
things right it can it can be a little
bit annoying it can feel like your
opponent
is somehow like you know cheating
cheating chess
right they're going against the laws of
chess and getting away with it somehow
trying to score some free wins
uh but that's that's not really the
right way to to look at it the right way
to look at it
is to say yes thank god my opponent is
giving me
this advantage right out of the opening
now i can
sort of just follow my opening
principles and i should have a good
position
right and that's exactly the right way
to approach this
in the game i did capture on d4 because
i control the square more times than he
does he has absolutely no right to be
putting his pawn there
white continued with f3 and now
rather than give up my claim in this
center
over the e4 square i decided to fully
accept
by capturing on f3
and then my opponent plays the strange
looking move
queen takes f3 which if patrick daly is
in the chat tonight which it looks like
he's not which is a real shame
i think this is patrick's uh sort of
favorite line
uh he likes taking with the queen it's
called apparently
the writer gambits and the idea
is that black maybe should take on d4
but by breaking an opening principle by
spending time with the queen
to capture this uh second pawn
then white is going to get very rapid
development and get some play against
the black
queen so i am going to tell you outright
queen takes d4 is objectively the best
move
in the position so now practically
should i play queen takes d4 being
unfamiliar
with this queen coming to f3 i'm even
giving you
more information than i had at the board
at the board i didn't know
i had a an inkling that queen takes d4
is probably just correct
you know white's giving up all of their
center pawns how can i not take this
but i wasn't sure now i'm telling you
100 queen takes d4 is great for black
black is objectively winning
after queen takes d4 should i take it
and if not
what should i do
manny says so for the black mardemer you
need to play knight c3 before
c4 um
generally yes i think you can also start
with e4
and play it against the kero con
something like e4 c6 d4
d5 and then um
knight c3 d takes e f3 some some line
like this
take it it's a free juicer says carlo
says carlo
so yeah as i said queen takes d4 is
great
grabbing a central pawn but it is
slightly breaking some opening
principles right we've already captured
one pawn here
do we really want to be developing out
uh our queen
into the center when we know our
opponent is going to have a variety of
ways
to sort of capitalize against it taking
tempo move after temple move after tempo
move against the queen
right that's the kind of thing you
really only want to do
if you feel like you're well prepared
and you know
you know you know all the complications
right i didn't know all the
complications so i think queen takes d4
is a practical mistake
right it's definitely possible for a
move to be objectively correct
but practically the wrong decision and
here i think queen takes d4
is practically just the wrong decision
so what do i do instead i don't go
knight c6 as some people in the chat
were saying
i want to make sure that i am getting a
little bit of a hold
in the center right now white has all of
the control
so i play the move e6 right i don't need
to develop this bishop out to g4 right
away
i just want to make sure i have a bishop
in front of my king
the opportunity to castle if i decide
that that is the side of the board
i belong on and you know just good play
just
get my pieces into the game
my opponent continued with bishop to e3
which i think is maybe
uh a bit of a mistake because like
i didn't take this pawn last turn am i
really gonna take the pawn on the next
turn why not bishop f4
and get a little bit more active but
bishop b3 was played
and now i continue with bishop to b4
right just because i'm up a pawn doesn't
mean i'm ready to give up
all of these light squares in the center
so i'm just
doing very very simple very natural
development
still fighting for the same light
squares that i would
if my opponent hadn't sacrificed uh
his e4 pawn right you just follow
opening principles and develop your
pieces
and your position is fine bishop d3 is
how my opponent decided to continue
and now i do play the move knight c6 now
that i'm confident i have good control
over these light squares and white isn't
going to get some
crazy opening idea like d5 to go through
right just keeping all these ideas in
mind and developing my pieces
very very quickly now my opponent played
knight to e2 here and you know i had a
lot to say about white developing his
knight out in front of his pawn
and i just did the same thing right but
i did so with
again a same uh very direct purpose
you know and actually the same purpose
that that my white developed with
right i wanted to play the move e5 and
the point now
is that yes it looks like i'm trying to
open up the center
while i'm sort of the one you know that
should be on the defensive side trying
to consolidate
but the point is white has this central
advantage and i have an
opportunity to get rid of it and so i
should take it
in the meantime i'm opening the way for
my bishop to develop
and these opening principles i'm
following all throughout and that's
really all i'm doing right there's some
calculation going on here
but the moves themselves are rooted in
controlling the center
and developing the pieces uh my opponent
now actually goes a little bit astray
and plays the move d5 now
you know i didn't take the pawn when it
was free on d4 but now i have both my
knights out to their most natural
squares i have a nice pin
on the knight on c3 and i'm gonna take
this pawn
so i take a second pawn queen g3 is
played
now i'm not really interested in any
tactics against my queen
so i drop the queen back to e6 and now
let me ask you
should black be worried about queen
takes g7
in this position should we be worried
no and you guys are correct queen takes
g7
is not really going to be the hugest
concern for black in this position
why not well what was once a spatial
advantage in the center
for white is now a spatial advantage in
the center
for black i am the one with more control
over these central squares
thanks to my actively placed pieces
right we followed the opening principles
developed our pieces towards the center
and we are rewarded
by having a strong e5 pawn whereas our
opponent
threw his e4 pawn away like it was trash
uh so queen takes g7 is not the biggest
concern
of all time uh
also tactically there is this move rick
g8
and after queen h6 there are some ideas
of black taking back
on g2 so tactically it works out and
principally
black should really have nothing to
worry about with two extra pawns and
better central control
so white does the correct thing here and
just queen side castles
just kidding the rest of his pieces
developed
and now i play the move bishop d7
so what do you think about the move
bishop d7 is it a good move
or could black do better here could
black do better here
can black do better than bishop d7
why not casual castle says danilo and
he's uh incredibly perfectly correct
castle's king sight is the best move for
black
and i think it's just very clearly a
mistake to go bishop d7 here
with the idea of queen side castling
this is what i thought i was going to do
with the black pieces but this is just
wrong
why is this wrong well i didn't cast the
king's side
because i was afraid that my opponent
was going to checkmate me
why was i afraid that my opponent was
going to checkmate me because you know
he did scary things like
f3 and then took and and came over here
with this queen
early on in the opening however
um another title to this lecture could
have been you know trust
your opening principles right the
opening principles
don't normally lead you astray and
here i have better central control i've
almost completed development
only needing to get this bishop out
um and often times that this queen side
bishop is the last piece to get
developed
it's not really the most critical thing
to the safety of the king on the king's
side
and since i control the center since my
pieces are developed
i should have no problem castling king's
side here now of course chess is a game
of specifics and you should be
trying to calculate these things to make
sure there's no
checkmating attack but it turns out that
this is the truth here
and it's not hard to understand why this
knight on e2
is not going to attack me anytime soon
it's
stuck hampered by this space the space
this pawn on e5 gives me
this knight on e4 uh the only square
could really
come to is e4 and sorry i'm talking
about the knight on c3
and if it does so it's going to be
captured
and now is it going to be captured i was
going to say there's ideas of f5 but of
course that that would be a pretty big
mistake
um but here okay there are ideas of of
queen takes a2
as well right so this knight's going to
come check
not going to come checkmate me this
knight's not going to come checkmate me
this bishop is well placed this bishop
could come to
the h6 square but tactically just loses
to knight h5
could come to the g5 square but then
simply 98 is fine for black
and so while white does have a few
actively placed attacking pieces
really it's not going to be enough to to
actually check mate black on
the king's side here because once again
black has a nice
control over the center of the board
thanks to the opening principles
so castling would have been nice but i
played bishop d7 instead
rook h to f1 was played and i go
queen g4 now offering up a queen trade
and
again i think castles was a little bit
better
queen g4 isn't a bad move it still
maintains the advantage
but again i think the opening principles
dictate that i should have castled here
and i should have just trusted them
but i did not i play queen g4 and the
queen dips back to f2
of course white cannot be trading uh the
queen's off the board he's down
two pawns uh i continue now with a6
which is again a bit of a mistake i
still wanted the castle on the queen
side
so i was a little [ __ ] and i was
worried i was gonna get checkmated so i
wanted the castle over here
and this pawn would have been under
attack but okay
a6 played now h3 forces my queen back
again
and now my opponent could have gone
queen g3
with some nice threats on my slightly
weakened
uh king side if i try and castle
queenside which i think was my plan in
the game then queen takes g7 is at least
regaining a pawn
and there are some complications here
after something like knight f4
my knight's a little bit stuck so it
probably has to come to f4
and black or white is definitely still
in the game um
with with the move like queen g3
honestly again maybe kingside castles is
the best move right you can guard some
of the weaknesses actually with
the king but instead my opponent played
bishop f5 which is sort of the worst
move of all time
because i take it and after takes takes
takes takes six
now black is just up two pawns with
nothing to worry about
right white is not going to get some
kind of check mating attack black is
just
simply up two pawns extra central space
and is pretty much fully developed right
we still need to castle
but that can be done uh actually
immediately in the position
uh in the game i chose bishop d6 instead
just staying solid with my e5 pawn
bishop g5 was played knight d7 knight e4
f6 forces the bishop back and defends
this guy
and white captured here i took back
bishop h4
knight e7 forces this rook back rook f3
d5 rook b3 b5
bishop f2 and after king f7 my rooks are
connected
and black is winning the game with uh
with two extra pawns
i played through all those moves rather
quickly but white was sort of just
busted and i wanted to end
on a nice clean king f7 when uh when my
rooks are connected
and black is just winning
was the opponents uh around like 1850
that i introduced
at the top of the lecture
so of course bishop f5 was a little bit
of a misstep by the opponent
but the point i was trying to get across
is that this line in particular
has a pretty nasty reputation for being
very very tricky it's a very trappy
opening
right white gets this queen out early on
and black often gets checkmated in the
center if he's not careful
and i was unfamiliar with it but what i
was familiar with
are were the principles of the opening
and just by following those developing
the pieces controlling the center
that is enough to survive many of these
crazy tricky openings
you just do what is natural what you
know the chess books all
all told you what they taught all those
little russian school boys
when they were learning the game of
chess and and they usually don't guide
you astray
um okay so questions on on this game
right questions on on this game before i
move on
because so far we looked at two pretty
um
distinct examples where
my opponents were not so much following
the the greatest principles
and you know in this game i definitely
had my mistakes bishop d7 i think was
was pretty clearly wrong when castles
would have been the the full advantage
for black
but uh in general i tried to follow the
principles
and it did work out well
what is the immediate idea of punishing
queen takes d4 after queen f3
well we are moving outside my realm of
expertise
but queen takes d4 bishop e3
maybe this queen would have to move
again
queen f2 something like e5
knight f3 and uh the queen's kind of
just floating out here right
maybe also some ideas of just going
bishop
like f4 or something and then like
yeah there's knight b5 i don't know i
don't know i'm outside you
you're asking questions i don't don't
know the answer to here all i know
is that my opponent definitely didn't
blunder queen takes d4 and was gonna
know more about the position than i did
and why would i you know sort of let
myself
fall into these kinds of lines when uh
when i knew my opponent
knew what he was doing better and i was
sort of sacrificing a lot of time
for the d4 pawn
so yeah later in the game i actually
mess everything up and then i
i have to win a slightly tricky rook end
game but this is an openings lecture so
we don't need to talk about that
but all right let us move along i wanted
now
to go over a rapid game that i played
don't do that every day
but uh yeah lately i have been playing
some some rapid chess only chess some
ten plus zero
that's as close as i'm getting to real
chess these days real over the board
chess
uh you know just games where i'm taking
things a little bit more seriously
and i'm actually getting some
instructive content which by the way
if you like these lectures boy oh boy do
i have good news for you
because i've actually started my own
youtube channel where i uploaded
uh me playing a rapid game
live and then actually some game
analysis i did
against one of the best players on lead
chess uh and then uh
recently i uploaded just in endgame
study so
shameless self promotion there but if
you like
this sort of game analysis stuff i'm
doing a little bit of that on my own
channel now as well so check it out it's
just my name
it's that easy just look up caleb dunby
anyways
this rapid game in particular is not on
my youtube channel
and spanish flash plays the move e4
i go c6 we have the carrot khan d4
d5 knight c3 takes on e4 takes on e4
bishop f5 uh knight g3 attacks the
bishop and bishop g6
so once again i played very quickly
through the first five moves
and you can say yeah chess is all theory
because look you know you can't use
principles on those first five moves
and well really you can
it's just that like depending on which
moves you decide to play that are
are equally principled you're playing
just an entirely different opening so
fast forwarded through all of those and
we have arrived at the classical
variation of the caro khan
now of course e there are long longer
theoretical lines with moves like
h4 moves like knight e2 to f4
moves like yeah those two
moves like knight f3 as well are all
fine but
here my opponent played the move c3
so c3 is definitely not a theoretical
move
this is sort of a nothing move by white
it's almost passing the turn back to
black
there are situations when this pawn
coming to c3 is going to be useful for
white
but to play it sort of outright i i
think is just a bit
wrong so how do i punish my opponent
for playing a slow looking move that
doesn't really help his position
early on well of course i just continue
development
and control the center right that's all
you need to do
when your opponent is doing something
wrong you just finish development
control the center and then you will get
a perfectly fine position
bishop d3 is how my opponent decided to
follow things up
i developed with knight f6 i could have
taken on d3
but i saw no rush bishop takes g6 is
fine for white but
h takes g6 isn't exactly a terrible pawn
structure for black either
in the game my opponent goes knight 1 to
e2
so what do you think about this move
knight 1 to e2
knight 1 to e2
brian asked that i have to move the
bishop well it was under attack right
so usually
usually you gotta you gotta move that
guy
so yeah you guys are asking all the same
questions that i was asking
and here's where uh it comes in handy
to if you remember sort of the the most
famous lecture i've ever did
is don't memorize moves understand your
openings and
knight 1 to e2 is is a pretty
fundamental misunderstanding of this
this line in the carob con
right so i mentioned the move knight 1
to e2 here and here is a perfectly
reasonable move
but you have to understand that knight 1
to e2 is with the idea of putting a lot
of pressure on this bishop
on g6 what do i mean by that well the
whole point of this line
is that you go h4 and if black isn't
careful
h5 traps the bishop or
h6 trying to give the bishop a square is
now clearly punished by knight takes g6
right so that is the main point of this
line there's another point sometimes
where this knight is ganging up uh on
the e6 pawn with the help of this bishop
and i think you play h4 there but it
doesn't really matter
but with c3 first d3 and then knight one
to e2
the obvious issue with this is that
number one
he's not getting the e6 pressure that
the knight on e f4 sometimes exerts
and number two and the idea of trapping
the bishop is obviously a little bit
flawed
when the bishop can trade itself off at
at any moment so
knight one to e2 is misunderstanding the
ideas
behind the opening which is what that
other lecture i taught was about
but it's also just breaking a principle
right uh i was talking earlier f3 is
sort of just the best square for the
knight
because it controls the center more
thoroughly
no reason not to put it there so what do
i do to punish my opponent for his you
know blatant misunderstanding of the
opening
well i hit him with the killer bishop e7
developing my pieces and castling my
king god how do i refute chess openings
so
well kingside castles for white
king side castles for black and then my
opponent reveals
his devious idea to me he wanted to play
f4 so tell me chat should i be scared of
f4
f4 certainly looks scary but should i be
scared
nay so why should i not be scared
why should i not be scared
so this is where you know the power of
playing principal chess
really comes in handy right if you're
playing some
really offbeat line where you're sort of
flaunting the principles
and you know playing some crazy gambit
or something where you know probably you
might objectively be worse
then if your opponent hits you with the
move that you you either don't remember
you didn't see before
it's entirely possible that your
position is just like worse and you're
losing
right so if you're not following
principles
uh if you're trying to play these tricky
offbeat lines
that is the major uh risk that you run
right running into something you're not
familiar with when in fact
you you might might have misremembered
something earlier on and you could
potentially
very much be worse with one wrong move
whereas here
by playing principle chess following the
principles
you always sort of have this fallback
where it's like well
you know what did i do with my time
let's review right
i played the kero khan i took on e4
the main line i developed my bishop my
bishop was attacked so i moved it
i developed i developed i developed
i castled and then my opponent played f4
so
every single move that black has played
has been as efficient as possible
has been geared directly towards
developing and castling
there has been no wasted time for black
so there's absolutely no reason to be
afraid of f4
why because we couldn't have played any
better we played all the best moves
right you can't be worse after f4 if
you've just played all of the best moves
so after f4 the obvious idea is to come
to f5
and so i decided it was time to trade
off these bishops and then as some
people in the chat were saying
the move c5 is the natural carol move we
don't even have to react
to this pawn on f4 we can just go c5
break in the center and make use of our
more efficient develop
development and more efficient setup
compared to white um now the move f5
isn't even playable because black has
the move e5
again wouldn't it be nice if this knight
was on f3 to control this square a
little bit
but it's not it's sitting here sad on e2
and after bishop e3 black is quite
severely better here uh it's almost
-1 if you ask an engine well actually
probably closer to minus
0.6.7 but it's still pretty good
right it's pretty good for move 12 with
the black pieces minus 0.7
um so after bishop e3 i make a a very
very serious mistake in the game
which you know it's a rapid game these
these mistakes kind of happen
uh the way black should continue it's
just very very simple
you go knight c6 you finish development
white's
probably going to go something like rook
8 d1 finishing development
himself queen b6 now and bringing the
rooks to the center of the board
is perfectly good for black and again
black is going to have some advantage
largely because this knight on e2
is just the worst piece of all time it
almost can't legally move if it weren't
for the c1 square
this knight would literally be unable to
move
um in the game though the serious
mistake that i make is actually taking
on d4
and this is of course just helping white
because now this knight is back into the
game
and despite white's bad opening play i
don't think white is too much
worse anymore because the main issue for
for white was this knight and now this
knight is sort of fixed so
my mistake there and now white is very
much back in the game
that being said of course black still
should not be worse
again because black hasn't done enough
wrong
all of black's moves are developing the
pieces and controlling the center
so i continue with knight c6 white
brings rook to the d
file and now my development still isn't
quite done
i need to connect my rooks bring them
into the center so i go queen c7
just preparing to bring the rook over
and finish my development and get on
with my life you know play my chess game
in the game white tried knight e4 which
uh is
pretty accurately described as giving up
right you you play f4
going for some kind of attack and the
next thing you know you're you're sort
of the one begging for trades because
you you don't know what else to do
uh in the game i just continued with
rook f to d8
and white traded on f6 uh queen e4
to un-pin and then i captured
we liquidated i went rook d7
uh preparing to double up on the d file
myself and
it was a quality uh which can
occasionally happen in chess
but it's important to understand that
getting a quality uh out of the opening
is not a bad thing with with the black
pieces
right and i missed my shot to be better
by taking on d4 a little bit too early
allowing this knight to escape the game
continued with dirk d1
rick d8 king f2 now after queen b6 i
think again black is just a little bit
better
uh because white sort of inaccurately
plays this move king f2 which allows me
to put this rook in a pin
put some pressure on over here the game
continued with king e3
and now the move f5 is actually very
very awkward for white to meet
the game he went queen e5 i went rook d5
and then white resigned
uh largely because this queen has zero
squares
that it can move to and partially
because my opponent didn't realize the
game could have continued with the move
king
to f3 with the idea of white getting two
rooks for the queen
although that position also does favor
black but
wasn't meant to be no king f3 with the
rook d
eight and her mesos uh
when again i think black should be a bit
better with queen takes b2
but instead rook d5 and white resigns
so somehow someway in 23 moves black
ended up winning this game
did i do anything crazy no i developed
my pieces
controlled the center and got a good
position and that is what is
going to happen if you follow the
opening principles
okay so uh
questions for me on this game or on the
the lecture in general
it's pretty pretty good says jared i
tend to agree
on the o'kelly
i have not given a lecture on the o
kelly and i'm not entirely certain
about the o'kelly
you make all the logical moves and end
up a piece down after 3d4
how do you end up a piece down after 3d4
i have no idea what simon's talking
about
but i will do some investigating
i'm doing well thank you for asking
basher
is there a book on opening principles um
i mean there are off the top of my head
which one would i recommend
um there's one series uh
maybe it's called mastering chess
openings uh that jonathan
schrantz recommends uh a lot to uh to
newer players but then again you see how
that guy turned out he's out here
playing
playing crazy gambits all day long so i
don't know
best opening for black uh tough
i'll pass let's selling with 2a6 okay
well i think i am going to go ahead and
call it after actually
one last question uh the question was
why did i take on d4 and the answer was
you know i was being a bit lazy i guess
moves like knight a5 heading for c4
perfectly fine
97 is perfectly fine as well f5 is
sometimes a threat but it's not really
the
the most severe threat in the world um
and i thought i was going to get some
advantage
by taking here uh i was a bit wrong with
the mover of d7
but uh yeah i thought it looked like
it's fine for me so i just went ahead
and played it
maybe knight a5 is a better way to keep
the game going but i didn't play it in
the game
now what rating level does color even
matter for like 500 level players is
there even advantage
with white i mean it depends uh jaelix i
think there's a lot of value
in being able to steer the game towards
the position
you are comfortable with not necessarily
that's objectively great for you
but just a position that you are
comfortable with that holds a lot of
value
especially at the lower levels as well
and so if you can do that more
effectively with the white pieces then i
would say there's there's some advantage
there
but okay let's call it here if you guys
want to join me on
twitch directly after this the fun will
be continuing
with tactics time i would also encourage
you guys to go check out
my own youtube channel that's just
getting started
um hopefully you enjoy some of the
content i'm putting out there as
well and that is going to do it for us
tonight
thank you all so much for tuning in uh
as always
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time
you